[Musique]
la revue de presse des territoires le
meilleur de la presse régionale du jour
concocté pour vous par fanny conquis
fanny qu'est ce qui lie à la une de nos
journaux régionaux aujourd'hui alors je
vous propose de commencer cette revue de
presse avec ouest france et ce titre
urgent le chantier de l'hôpital est tout
vert en effet le ségur de la santé des
buts et igert le gouvernement et les
partenaires sociaux ont un mois et demi
pour réformer le système de santé
plusieurs sujets sont sur la table la
revalorisation des salaires bien sûr
mais aussi l'organisation du temps de
travail les effectifs les fermetures de
lits ou encore la tarification à l'acte
souvent pointé du doigt ces négociations
doivent aboutir à un plan qui sera
présenté en juillet autre secteur en
souffrance les ehpad le bien public
consacre sa une et une enquête à cette
question qui se pose et qui revient
depuis des semaines pourquoi autant de
morts dans les ehpad le journal rappelle
ces chiffres ni mais on pouvait estimer
qu'un tiers des mordus kobe 19 avait eu
dans les maisons de retraite
alors comment l'expliquer absence de
masques haut depuis la crise manque de
textes gestion par la rs
l'enquète sur cette faille majeure de la
gestion de la pandémie et à lire ce
matin dans le bien public
je vous propose maintenant de regarder
la une de la dépêche du midi edouard
philippe
doit-il partir il gère la crise depuis
des mois mais fera t-il les frais du
changement de cap voulue par emmanuel
macron si oui qui pour le remplacer
et quand faudra-t-il remaniée autant
d'énigmes bien difficile à résoudre
selon le dernier baromètre au doxa le
premier ministre bénéficie d'une cote de
popularité bien supérieure à celle du
président de la république
par ailleurs le profil de son remplaçant
est loin d'être évident enfin un
remaniement avant l'été semble délicat
les tractations politiciennes en effet
pourrait être mal perçu par l'opinion
publique alors que la crise du coc bible
mais pas encore terminée et justement
cette crise du coc vite 19 il ya un
homme qui pensait avoir la solution et
il est en une de la provence c'est bien
sûr le professeur didier raoult
depuis le début de la crise il vantait
les bienfaits de hydroxy chloroquine est
pourtant une étude remet en cause ce
traitement qui non seulement n'aurait
pas d'effet sur le virus mais qui en
plus pourraient s'avérer dangereux la
réponse de l'infection
marseillais ne s'est pas fait attendre
dans une vidéo et déclare je cite je ne
vais pas changer la vie à cause d'une
étude foireuse on le voit la querelle
scientifique n'est donc pas terminée et
puis pour finir cette revue de presse je
vous propose de nous projeter un peu sur
les vacances l'été à l'étranger oui mais
risqué naudy le télégramme
après deux mois de confinement certains
ont des envies d'ailleurs plusieurs pays
européens veulent rouvrir leurs
frontières pour les touristes mais le
gouvernement l'a dit il vaut mieux
privilégier la france
une avocate spécialisée du tourisme
souligne qu'en cas de rebond l'épidémie
les touristes seront davantage protéger
s'ils sont en france en terme d'
annulation de remboursement du séjour
par exemple cependant 60 millions de
consommateurs rappelle qu'il faut bien
lire les conditions avant toute
réservation
toutes les informations sur ses vacances
d'été à l'étranger sont à lire dans le
télégramme
et oui des vacances bleu blanc rouge cet
été merci beaucoup fanni pour cette
revue de la presse régionale